طالع المحطات الموجوده في البلد عدا الضخم
المشغلين الرئيسيين للشركات المصنفه يعني
ما اعتقد انهم يصلون 20% 25% من المحطات
اللي موجوده في البلد
بالعكس مجال التطوير والعمل فيه انا اعتقد
انه واعد جدا حتى مع توجهنا وهذا اتوقع
المستقبل البعيد خاصه في السعوديه خاصه
سيارات الكهربائيه حتى مع
يلا حيهم اتوقع اغلبنا يعرف محطات ساسكو
قد عبى بنزين فيها او على الاقل اشترى شيء
من محلاتها واذا كنت ما تعرفها فاي شركه
عندها اكثر من 500 محطه بنزين وكانت يمكن
اول شركه فيها القطاع تركز على تقديم
تجربه مميزه العملاء من خلال عدد كبير من
محطات عموما ضيفنا اليوم ابراهيم الحذيثي
رئيس مجلس اداره شركه ساسكو بنبذلفتنا
معاه حول تجربته في تاسيس اول محطه بنزين
اللي بمناسبه ما كانت ساسكو وش السبب اللي
خلاه بعد سنوات يقرر يستحوذ على شركه
ساسكو ويطورها بالشكل اللي يطمح له ثم
نتكلم عن كل عنصر من عناصر محطات البنزين
ابتداء بالبنزين نفسه والتسعير والرقابه
عليه ثم التموينات
بدال ما يتعاقدون مع احد وتجربتهم في
المطاعم والمقاهي وغيرها من الخدمات اللي
تقدمها المحطات فبخص كل وحده فيهم وخلال
الحلقه بنغطي نقاط كثير تخص هالقطاع مثل
ليش ما شفنا الحين انتشار للخدمه الذاتيه
في المحطات او انتشار لخدمات التوصيل
البنزين البيوت وهل بنشوف شوائح من
السيارات الكهربائيه قريب في محطات
البنزين وغيرها حلقه اثريه جدا مع اول مره
اغطيه في البرنامج اتمنى تعجبكم حياك الله
ابو محمد الله يبقيك سيف امورك عساك بخير
الله يسلمك يمكن اول ضيف نستضيفه في
القطاع محطات البنزين في تفاصيل كثيره
نحتاج نمر عليها في الحلقه بس يمكن نبداها
اول شيء في وش دخلك القطاع على اساسا هل
كان في عندك تجاره سابقا ثم قررت انك محطه
بنزين ولا انه مثلا جت فكره البنزين من
البدايه شو كان مدخل للمحطات البنزين انا
كان عندي البزنس اشتغل حقي ما كان في قطاع
محطات بنزين ولكن مع حماس الشباب والعمل
فيه وكذا
بكل صراحه وتجرد اللي دخلني غير محطات
البنزين هو انه ابحث عن عمل يوم الخميس
والجمعه كان عندك شيء كان عندي عمل في
المقاولات والتجاره وكذا لكني يعني ذيك
الايام اطالع وين يوم الخميس والجمعه شو
بسوي المزرعه وكذا وبعدين يعني ما عندي
نشاط كبير رئيس اسويه
يعني
هل
اسبوع تسوي لك عمل تشتغل فيه فقعدنا نفكر
فيه وش المجال الكذا وجدت انه قطاع محطات
الوقود والخدمات داخل المدن يعني في نهايه
الاسبوع في عمل كثير وتميز يصير فيه نوع
من الحركه اقدر اول شيء يشتغل طول الاسبوع
هذه عام 84 ما شاء الله 1984
محطه بنزين كيف تبدا
والله في البدايه كانت ذيك الايام صعبه
لانه هذيك الايام يعني انا اقول لا اذكره
اول محطه سويتها خذاني الترخيص فيها عشان
اطلع لها ترخيص حوالي سنه كامله والله
معامله وكذا واجراءات يعني كنت انا بطلعها
في الخرج فكل الاشياء
الانظمه والتخطيط والامور هذه كان لازم
ترجع للرياض وترجع الرياض يقول لك والله
راح اغير استخدام الارض من سكني او تجاري
الى محطه وقود وكانت قصه طويله
المحطه الاولى استغرقت مني وقت طويل يعني
اكثر من سنه بس ما كانت لا لا كان نجمه
المدائن ما بدات نجمه المدائم
فاشتغلنا فيها
ومع التجربه والخبره اللي صارت بهذا
المجال المحطه الثانيه اخذت مني يمكن
ثلاثه شهور ترخيص اللي بعدها المحطات
الثانيه ما صارت تاخذ مننا شهر شهر ونص
لانه عرفنا البوسيجر والنظام
والدوره حقتها والحمد لله رب العالمين
وكان نفس نظام محطات اليوم اللي هي
متكامله في كل الخدمات ولا بس بس والله
اول ما نفذنا المحطه الاولى والثانيه كانت
محطات رخام
متكامله كل شيء موجود فيها يعني جميع
القطاعات من وقود صيانه
سوبر ماركت محلات تجاريه يعني وصلنا الى
صالون حلاقه كان فيها
اذا كانت يعني نحاول تكون متكامله
فيعني وفقنا فيها الحمد لله
مجينا ذيك الايام متكلم عن
محافظ زي الخرج هذيك الايام الخدمات
والارتقاء فيها ورفع مستواها كان يعتبر
شيء يعني غريب ومتقدم لانه احنا اعتمدنا
يعني في تجارتنا فيها والشغل فيها نروح
نقتبس وش اللي يعني وين وصلوا هالناس هذيك
الايام يمكن في الرياض
وجده المنطقه الشرقيه ما تلقى فيه يعني
ثلاث اربع محطات تقول هذه كامله ومتكامله
فيها جميع الخدمات يعني كان عدد قليل
الباقي لا هو كان في نموذج خطه صغيره يعني
خدمات بسيطه عن بنزين وامشي وش جابك
الفكره هذه كان في نموذج يعني شفته في
مكان ثاني مكان فيه كان فيه محطه في
الرياض يعني تعتبر جدا متقدمه كان ذيك
الايام في شارع
شارع الضباب
وفي شارع المعذر كان في محطتين مميزه
بالرياض ذكريات يعني يعني اذا رات لها
تشعر انه والله مقدم الخدمه يعني محترم
الزبون كثير فكان يتعلق بالراز شوي
اشتغلنا عليها طبعا ماني يمنع على الصرف
وعلى رفع جوده على انه المباني كانت رخام
وجميله
لانه
ساعدتنا في التسويق تدري انت في مدينه
صغيره وفي منطقه صغيره اذا جيت وعملت شيء
مميز حيكون هدف للناس كله يعني حنا كان
هدفنا ذيك الايام في المبيعات انه النص
الى مبلغ معين اما فتحنا اول محطه يعني
بفضل من الله يمكن ضعفين اللي حنا نبيه من
البنزين ولا
غير الخدمات الثانيه في الخدمات الثانيه
كانت تجيب الناس
الخدمات كذا اول ما جاب الناس اللي هو
جوده المبنى توزيعه الخدمات نظافته هذه
خدمتها كثير بس انت كنت
محطتين كان فيها رخام وكبير كانك محطات
اللي بعدها نفس نفس في الخرج بس انت كانك
تو يعني انك كانت بس اول محطتين كذا
والمحطات الباقيه تغيرته
نطلع بدينا نطلع
ما انت حطيت الاسم
وحطيت يعني الخدمات صار الناس يلمسون يعني
جوده في الخدمات واضحه وصار يعتبر نفسه
انه عميل عندك ودائما ينتمي للاسم هذا
والمقدمه بدانا نروح
للمحطات اللي هي المستاجره ونجي نسوي
المباني طبعا الجوده النظافه
مستوى ما نلعب فيه
يعني اروح استاجر عرض وابني عليه المبنى
انت كنت تشتري الارض اول ما بدينا كانت
اراضي ملك حلو وش خلاك عشان تزيد العدد
وتس
رع في الين يجيك داخل وبعدين تجمع مال
وتبني محطه
تقريب كل سنه
تضطر من كل اربع سنين محطه فتحفظ بسيوله
اعلى تقدر توظفها بهالطريقه بدل ما يكون
عندك معطر عندك اربعه احيانا في مواقع
مميزه انت لازم تستاجرها ما هي يعني
حكوميه
ما تذكر الايام يعني انا كنت مستعجل من
وزاره الماليه عرض
ب 11
هذيك الايام كانت تجي على عشر سنين عشر
سنوات
الافراد مستاجر منهم على 15
وفضل من الله يعني الخدمات عندنا ممتازه
نفس المؤجرين يعني يرتاح انك تدفع له
الايجار في وقته
وما متعاون معه المبنى يكون جدا ممتاز ما
عنده ملاحظات يعني شدون الناس في ملكه
وترتفع قيمته يعني يكون حريص انه يعني اذا
عنده فرصه ثانيه يجي ياجر علينا وتوسعت
برا الخرج بعدين بعد ما يعني تقريبا
ثمان تسع محطات بعدين طلع من الرياض لنفس
النموذج نفس كل شيء لا ما كانت ما كانت
هويه
زي ما هو الان يعني كان نجي على نوع
المنطقه الموقع الامور نعمل جوده ونعمل
طريقه لكن فيها احيانا المباني تكون يعني
ذيك الايام احنا الاساس مبانينا خرسانيه
وبعدين بدينا نروح للحديد نروح يعني
الجوده بمواد مختلفه قصدك انك طلعت مختلفه
حتى
اكملت على نجمه المدينه كملنا على المدائن
المحروقات
تقريبا الى 2006 حلو 2006
رحنا وعملنا يعني تطوير للعمل عندنا
وحولنا غيرها اسم الشركه الى شركه زيتي
حملناها يعني عملنا لها نظام واداره
مستقله عن المجموعه وبداوا يعملون يطورون
يمشون في المجال هذا وينطلقون يعني يعملون
لهم فروع خارج
الخارج والرياض بداوا ينتشرون يعني
فبدة تقريبا
وكم محطه اعتقد انه فوق العشرين
اكثر ومع زيتي بديته ايضا المحطات القديمه
استمرت بنفس الاسم استمر الزيتي كله تحول
شركه كلها تحولت الى يعني غيرنا الاسم الى
زيت
السابقه عملنا لها تطوير وعمل يعني وتمشي
على الاسم الجديد حلو وش جابكم كانت شركه
موجوده وقتها يعني ما هي ما هي الشركه
كانت موجوده الظاهر انه من عام الثماني
ن قبل ما ادخل انا البزنس يمكن باربع سنين
وكم كان محطه
لكن نقدر يعني اقول لك
اما احنا استحوذنا على اساسكم
استحوذنا على اساسكم عندهم 39 محطه
هذه 2009 حلو بس قبل الاستحواذ يعني من
يوم ما حولته الى زيتي اموركم
كيف كيف دخلت في الرادار عندكم بديت
تفكرون تستحون عليها خاصه حسب علمي على
الاقل انه ساسكو وقتها ما كانت يعني
سمعتها جيده وهداها جيده
مسافر أنا سلطان
يعني رايحين ثاني اخوي سلطان هو اللي محطه
لا سلطان اصغر مني كثير بس انه كان يعني
ما متخرج ويعمل كنا نعمل مع بعض في بعض
الشركات في القطاعات الثانيه حنا مش
مسافرين كنا نمر من عند محطات بين المدن
والخدمات يعني كانت جدا تعيسه
فقعدنا نسولف انه يعني حرام هذا المجال
موجود عندنا هو يعني اول ما بدينا بالبزنس
كان جانبي هو بالنسبه لنا مو براسي فقعدنا
نتكلم عن كل يوم ناخذه ونعطي ناخذ ونعطي
وش الافضل الاشياء هل ننطلق بزيتي
ونكمل ونروح ندخلها الى سوق المال او نعمل
يعني
زياده فروع على الطرق السريعه او انه
في موجود شركه يعني
ما نقول متاثره لكن شبه متعثره
خدماتها
مهب اكل خدمات ما فيها ما في جوده ما في
تطوير
لكن عندها مزايا
تعطيك الوقت توفر فيها وقت كثير زي انه
خلاص هي موجوده بشركه في سوق المال فما
تروحوا في السوق ومرتاح وخلاص هذا جانب
ايجابي كويس
الجانب السلبي هو عدم رضا العملاء
على الشركه ما كانوا الناس راضيين حنا جزء
من الشريحه ما كانت راضيه مسافر في اي
مكان كنت تجد محطات
رديع في كل مجال من ضمنها محطات ساسكو
فيزيتك كم شريك المحطه
لحالك
سلطان شريك حلو في 2006 ففي بالنسبه
او انك تستحوذ على شركه مطروحة وقتها ايش
كانت طرح شيء مهم بالنسبه لك
الطرح كان بالنسبه لنا كثير مهم لانه
يساعدنا في اشياء كثيره يعني لما اجي انا
اروح القى مواقع
سواء انا راضي
لناس او لشركات او اراضي حكوميه لما تيجي
انت
بشركه مطروح بسوق بسوق المال في هذاك
الوقت حيكون في نوع زياده من الثقه وزياده
من التجاوب وممكن يعني يكون فيه نوع من
الافضليه
في الخدمه هذا ما يعني اللي حنا كنا يعني
نحط من ضمن الخيارات احتماليات انه يعني
حتكون مريحه لانك اذا كان شركه مطروحه
بجديه اكبر مقارنه كثير
وانتشارها وخاصه انها شركه يعني مؤسسه من
1980 يعني فيها فيها نوع من المزايا وتقدر
تنطلق منها وهذا حصل فعلا ولا كان افتراض
احنا افترضنا لكنه اما استحوذنا ما حصل
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
كيف كانت عمليه الاستحواذ يعني لو ناخذها
تفاصيل اكثر
الاستحواذ قلت لكم محنا قاعدين نفكر يعني
في النقاش فيها الرحله في الراحه والرجعه
للمطار من هالرحله
قبلنا تناقش فيها وناخذ الارقام ونراجع من
هنا وجدنا انه يعني خلاص افضل خيار ناخذ
نستحوذ على الشركه
وانه نعرف وش المزايا في مزايا وفي عيوب
كثيره
هذيك الايام اما تجينا نستحوذ كانوا الناس
زي اللي يقول لك يعني هذه غلطه كبيره كيف
انتوا تروحون تحطون اسمكم في شركه عليها
اخفاقات في العمل الناس متضايقه من
المحطات الناس متضايقه من الخدمات من كيف
انتوا تروحون على المجال كان زياده تحدي
اما جينا نستحوذ الاستحواذ دائما
له يعني كذا طريقه
في طرق انه انت تروح مجموعه مستثمرين
تجتمعون او تروح للملاك الرئيسيين او
الناس اللي عندها اكثر اسهم في الشركه
وتعطيهم خطه عمل لكم برنامج وتحاول انه
انت تقرب بينهم وتجمع بينهم انه ياجماعه
بنسوي هالخطه كذا كذا كذا احيانا تنجح
واحيانا ما تنجح بس هذيك انه بيعوا الشركه
علينا مبيعه لا حطونا اصواتكم
وصوتوا لنا انه حنا نجي
نصير مجموعه ونسيطر على الشركه ونغير
ادارتها وننفذ خطه العمل اللي حنا نبغاها
حلو
اذا اذا جمعت الناس وجيت وقد شريت جزء
بسيط منها الاستحواذ الثاني هو انه تروح
تشتري الاغلبيه
وهو الشيء اللي عملناه حنا مجينا وجدنا
انه يعني مفترق طرق فيه ايجابيات وفي
سلبيات تحديات كبيره دخلنا وحنا يعني
جاهزين للتحديات اللي قدامنا اللي نعرفها
واللي ما نعرفها خلاص ماخذين خط لا رجع
فيه ايش اللي دعمنا زياده انه لازم تحط
انت مالك رحنا استحوذنا على عدد كبير من
اسهم الشركات
من السوق مجمعنا في السوق وشريناها من
السوق الين صار عندنا
الاغلبيه
المسار عندنا الاغلبيه احنا اللي كنا يعني
عملنا الخطه هذي كان باقي تقريبا
من سته الى تسعه اشهر على
انتخابات اداره جديد للشركه
فاستحوذنا بعد ما استحوذنا على الكميات
جينا
للعمل على استعراض الشركه جت الانتخابات
فزنا بفريق العمل حنا نبي المجموعه اللي
نبغاه وبعدين بدانا خطه التطوير الاستحواذ
كان تدريجي ولا خبطه واحده كذا ما تقدر
خبطه واحده لازم يعني تاخذ تحط لك خطه
وتبدا حسب المجال الموجود في السوق حسب ما
يباع ولا يمكن تيجي تستحوذ على شيء انت
تروح ترفع اسهم ولا تغير في سلوكيه السهم
خبره في الموضوع هذا هذه بدينا ناخذ يعني
تدريجيا يعني كل يوم نجمع عندنا خطه انه
تجمع كذا مليون سهم كل يوم كم تقدر تجمع
4500,000 سهم بدون ما تاثر على السهم بدون
ما يبين لانه انت تبغى تستحوذ على شيء
وعندك خطه عمل يجب انه يعني ما تؤثر على
الساعه ام وعلى طريقته عشان ما يرتفع سعره
يعني ما تبغى يرتفع ولا تبغاه يعني
تؤثر عليه ويدخل معك ناس يعني ممكن
يخربطون الشيء اللي انت قاعد تبغى خطه
العمل اللي انت بتسويها حلو فانتم استحوذت
على الشركه
طبعا
الشيء اللي حنا يعني
احنا نفتخر فيه
الشركه لما تجينا نستحوذ مجموعه
من
الرجالات العمل
تجاري المتنوع في منهم من يعمل في شركات
ماليه في منهم من يعمل في صناعه فيما يعمل
تجاره يعني مجموعه
ورحنا نستقطبهم يعني
تحاول فيه نضغط عليهم الا يجون عندنا
للمسجد نبغى نشكل على المجلس عندنا كذا
وهذا يعني
الخطه حقتنا حقت العمل وهذه طريقه التطوير
اللي بنعملها
فاخذت مننا جهد ولكن كان جهد جهد مميز انه
جميع الاخوان اللي عمله في مجلس الاداره
معنا من اول مجلس الى اليوم كلهم
ناس
تعمل للرقي بالشركه
وبالخدمات حقتها وتحقيق اهداف يعني يكونون
شركاء في نجاح هذه الشركه خلفياتهم
المختلفه ساهمت في تشكيل ساعدت كثير في
يعني لانه الشركه كبيره
ومجالاتها يعني متعدده فتحتاج ناس يعني
عندهم خبرات في كذا مجال وتختصر وتختصر
الوقت في سرعه التطوير بعدها قررت انك
تطور ساسكو وتوقف زيتي يعني تخليها تشتغل
زي ما هي صار عندك الان تدريانين المفروض
صح في زيتي وفي ساسكو
اتصور الحين وقفت
الله يرحمه كان هو ماسك العمل فيها وخطه
التطوير وكنا مو مجرد نراجع معه
العمل والتطور حقه كل تقريبا
ربع سنه
كملت
ساسكو كانت هي الهدف الرئيسي
لعده اسباب اول شيء احنا مركزين على
اساسكم اكثر
استثمارنا في ساسكو كان ضخم اكبر من زيتي
بكثير كنا كل ما نجي نزود الاستثمار نزوده
في ساعتكم
من البدايه
لا انا
من اول ما الشركه
رئيس مجلس اداره ومالك زيتي ما كان فيه
تعارض بين اثنين لا ما كان في تعارض يعني
كان الاساس عندنا هو اساسكم انه وقتها
لا هذه هذه نظام الشركات لازم انت كل سنه
تشعر الجمعيه وتاخذ منهم اذن انه انت تعمل
عمل كنثاني منافس
سنوي فصح ثانوي
عده سنوات يوم عرفنا الطريق يعني اشتغلنا
في الطريق واخذت مسار هذا الممتاز صار
عندنا لازم انه هذا يروح
سواء تاخذوا ساسكو او غير ساسكو حلو
يعني خلاص اخذنا قرار انه زيتي تطلع من
السوق
والله هذه الشركه من هنا وهذه شيء يعني
فيها تقريبا
عملوا تركيز كويس وهذه الشركه يمكن ضاره
هذي تعرف يعني حتى لو فاهمينه ما عندنا
مشكله احنا واضحين شفافين هذه المشكله
فاخذنا انه خلاص اخذنا
نركزكم سليم قانونيا برضو يتكلمون لكن حنا
ما كنا يعني نضع زيتي في
مسار يعني منافس
لساسكو كانت ساسكو هي الاساس
قررنا انه نتخلص منها لما يقررنا
جاءنا يعني ناس
منافسين ليس اسكو يبغون يشترونها حلو
حطونا يعني عروض كانت يعني كويسه جيده
افضل من عروض
ولكن نتيجه طالع انت تروح عندك تقريبا
شبكه فوق الاربعين محطه وتروح تعطيها
المنافسه لك هو تعديت ارقام وانت ما تعدي
نفس
افضل انها تاخذها حتى لو بعرض اقل بس على
الاقل حتى لو بعرض اقل لانه يعني
مهم ان الارقام حقتك ترتفع كويس في ساسكو
لا مبيعات لا عدد المحطات اشياء زي كذا
جدا مهمه
كنا اشتغلنا على الاستحواذ
بطريقه يعني مره شفافه واضحه انا ولا
سلطان لان علاقه احنا برا
الصفقه تماما دخلت القرار بيد العقاري
مجلس الاداره شركه ماليه متخصصه عندها
خبره كبيره اشتغلت على
الاستحواذ واشتغلوا عليه شغل
100% طبعا
ناقش الاخوان في مجري دارها اشتغلوا عليه
كثير وصلوا الى ارقام ممتازه وكذا كانوا
يعني يبغون يعصرون
الصفقه قد ما يقدرون
جو يتكلمون ما يتكلمون معنا روحوا تكلموا
مع
الرئيس التنفيذي مع الشركه منك واذا وصلت
الى طريق مسدود تعالوا
ما وصلت توكل على الله
مشوا في الموضوع وصلوا الى شبه يعني
طريق مسدود شويه انه والله احنا هم
مرافقين الا بهالمبلغ والتقييم كذا وهذا
رافضين هنا واحنا ما قدرنا يعني يعني نصل
الى رقم معين وفي منافس
اعلى وخلاص اخذنا قرار انه ما نبيع عليه
يعني موجود لكن مو بخيار لنا كيف نعطيه
يعني قوه اضافيه او يجي يمسك السوق فجلسنا
معهم طلعنا اقنعناهم انه يا جماعه
انتم المبلغ اللي بتبيعونه للمبلغ
المبيعات تقول والله ساسكو ضغطوا علينا في
المبلغ وانه اقل من المفروض المفروض يكون
اعلى من كذا وكذا انتم الان خيار لازم
تبيعون اذا بعتوا وشايفين انه اموركم ما
راح تكون يعني مو بالسعر اللي انتم تبون
الله لا يهينكم روحوا
المبلغ
المحطه بالكامل الا بس عندي اداره الا
قاعده تتكلم بهالموضوع تقول لك والله تعال
انا بدل ما ابيع بها المبلغ اعلى ويبغى يح
ققه كان بينتفعوني عن الموضوع لا ما عندهم
لا
مجرد عمل مع واحد كل واحد شاغل في عمل في
شركه دائما يحب انها تجيب يعني احسن رقم
ممكن او على الاقل يبغى يعني يكون
قيمه عادله مو بقلي شوي لكن الحمد لله
تمت اخذوا جزء منها حطوها اسهم في في
معناته انت مازلت مصر على الشركه لهم
وواثق فيها
ومستمر بالاستثمار فيها طيب
فعليا تمت انت اللي بتاخذ الفلوس الصفقه
صح اي تجي للشركه من شركاتي حلو
للشركه الرئيسيه اللي عندي القرار قرارك
المفروض الموظفين طلعوا منها الحين لا مو
شركه طبعا لها مجسي اداره ويعملون فيها
وينظمون يطالع استثمارهم
يعني تقريبا لي هي الشركه لكن عليها
ويعملون فيه ولهم خططهم لهم برامجهم فما
تقدر تشيل هذا على هذا يعني تقول له
اكثر الحين كم صار مجموع المحطات على على
وصلنا تقريبا يعني وصلنا الى حول الميتين
في 2009 ولا لا
بعد فتره
تشتغلون على تطوير خمس سنوات تقريبا
لتطوير ساسكو ماخذ منه تطوير سنه
اول قرار انه هذا يع
ملوها يقوي نفسه
ويثبت نفسه في السوق يبدا يتحسن وبعدين
يقدر يستحوث حلو في خلال الخمس سنوات
وش اللي تحسن ما كان موجود وصار موجود
كثير كثير
في المحطات
يعني اقول لك في 2009
اول ما استحوذنا على اساسكو طبعا كان شيء
الرئيسي انه عندك مجلس اداره عندك تبني
فريق عمل مميز تروح تعمل برنامج
وخطط وتعمل هويه وتطوير
للمحطات وهذه عملناها
الهويه خلصناها في 2010
يعني خذت مننا اقل من سنه اللي هي الاخيره
هويه الشركه وبعدين رحنا ونفذنا اول محطه
بالهويه الجديده اللي هي اخر وحده اليوم
موجوده
الان عدلنا يعني
بعد ما عملنا الهويه الجديده بدانا نشتغل
نطور في العمل يعني بتطورنا فيه تطويرات
كبيره واضفنا عناصر وبدينا نرجع الاسم
للسوق هويه جديده مميزه فيعني
الحقيب يعني الصحيح
انه
متلقي الخدمه
يعني دائما اذا احترمته وقدمته لخدمه
ممتازه تجد منه رده فعل ايجابيه انما
طورنا المحطات وعملنا ارتفع شيعه كثير
عندنا دفعت ارقام المبيعات
ارتفع العدد العملاء ارتفع عندنا كثير
وبهالطريقه
يقدرنا نتطور اسرع في اسرع ماجور ما شاء
الله تجربه يعني انك تروح لمحطه ساسكو ولا
اقولها مجامله صراحه بس الذهاب لمحطه
تجربه عموما سواء تجربه
ولا تروح لاي مكان واي خدمه داخل المحطه
غالبا اعلى من المحطات الثانيه بس هل في
شيء كنت معين كنت تعتقدون انه قاعد يقود
الارتفاع في الايرادات هذا من الخدمات
اللي تقدمونه ولا هو شيء يعني التطوير
الاجمالي للمحطه يرفع ارادتها والله شوف
التطوير وعدد العناصر اللي موجوده في
المحطه يعني انا اذكر اول محطه طورناها
اخذت مننا جهد كبير
عملناه استثمار ضخم بعدين اخذت منه جهد
كبير
ساسكو في استقطاب
شركات اللي ممكن تعمل معنا يعني
المحطات اول محطه طورناها بالهويه الجديده
كنا نبحث في هذيك الايام ما كان فيها تدخل
للمحطه عناصرها قليله اللي
بينشر غيار زيوت
بقاله تلقى ثلاث ارباع بضاعتها برا على
الرصيف
وعبنزينه وامش في امان الله هذه الخدمات
اللي موجوده فانت يعني حتى ضارب لك طريق
3400 كيلو ما تلقى
هل مثلا تقول تموينات النخله الفكره حقتها
هي اللي قاعده تجيب الناس المحطه او انه
لا والله التموينات والبنشر ويمكن المقاهي
بالمجمل هي اللي قاعده ترفع هل في عنصر
واحد اللي هذا اللي انا اقول لك الان انه
العناصر ما سوينا العناصر حقت
عناصر المحطه اللي وضعناها هي اللي خلت
الناس يعني
تجي للمحطه صار اسباب رئيسيه بس اشوفكم
مثلا من كل العناصر اللي عندكم التموينات
دائما انتم اللي تشغلونها الاهتمامات
النخله تبعكم
من الشركات اللي اساسها
العناصر اعطيك العناصر اللي احنا يعني
كانت بالنسبه لنا مهمه رئيسيه ونجحنا في
تحقيقها طبعا نحن اليوم عندنا العناصر
الرئيسيه اللي هي
لازم يكون عندك
اول شيء يكون عندك مسجد او مصلى يكون نظيف
خدماته جيده على اساس ان الناس اذا وقفوا
يجدون الخدمه هذه فيها الشيء الثاني يكون
عندك سوق سوبر ماركت ممتاز في جميع
العناصر في اشياء كويسه فيها معروفه
صلاحيه ما يبكي الا منتهي الصلاحيه وفيها
جوده وخدمات في عندك مطاعم
عندك
يعني
خدمات صيانه مميزه للسياره في الطريق لاي
شيء مع نظافه الموقع العام والمحطه
والهويه حقتها فاقول لك احنا ما سويناها
يعني اول محطه اللي فتحناها في 2010 كان
فيها عده مطاعم يعني فيها براندات اجنبيه
وسعوديه
يعني كل الناس اللي اشتغلوا معنا فيها
المحطه في اللي استقطبناهم اللي استقطناها
بسهوله ولا بصعوبه كلهم يعني نجحوا بها
التجربه
وصارت العمليه بالنسبه لنا سهله في سرعه
التطوير وهذا مشتركه بمغض النظر عن حجم
المحطه يعني كلها نفس العناصر ولا الطرق
السرية الطرق السريعه
دائما جميع العناصر
في
المدن دائما حسب الاحتياج وحسب حجم المحطه
وش اصغر شيء يعني وش العناصر لازم نتصور
يمكن مثلا
يعني اقل شيء يكون عندك مصلى عندك سوبر
ماركت عندك خدمات
هذه اقل شيء اذا محطه اكبر شوي عندك اللي
هو
يعني عندك مع الخدمات للمغسله مغسله
السيارات
يمسك العناصر واحد واحد نسولف للناس اللي
يمكن جديدين على البزنس هذا ابتداء
بالبنزين نفسه فعندي عده اسئله على
البنزين اول شيء للناس اللي ما يعرفون وش
اللي يتحكم في سعر البنزين خاصه الناس
دائما تحسسون صار في تغيير في الاسعار من
الحكومه لكن وش اجماله وش اللي يحكم سعر
البنزين وهل تقدرون تضيفون هامش ولا هامش
نفس سعر البيع ولا كيف طريقه النموذج
العمل في البنزين
البنزين من البدايات اللي هو يباع من
ارامكو
وفي سعر محدد في السابق كان السعر ينتج عن
يعني يطلع بامر ملكي انه سعر البيع على
المحطات
بالسعر الفلاني وسعر البيع على المستهلك
بهذا السعر وحاطين لك اللي هو
المارجن فرق الربح بين
وانت عليك النقل عليك كل شيء بس سعر البيع
موحد بجميع المحطات
في فرق بسيط يعطيك طرق السريعه عشان اللي
هو على النقل
وينفذ في بعض المحطات في بعد التطور عشان
اوضحها انت هامشك بينك وبين المزود ما
تقدر تاخذه من العميل لانه فعليا هو سعر
البيع واحد في جميع المحطات اهم شيء انا
من البيع اذا بعته يعني هو يبيعني مبلغ
معين معروف بكم باعني ومعروف الهامش حقي
انا سعر البيع على الافراد هذا معلن هو
السعر اللي دائما يعلن اي تغيير في
الاسواق يتغير يطلع فيها هو يحدد لك سعر
البيع لكن يبيع لك اياه بخصم بحيث تربح
منه
كانت عباره يعني تطلع اوامر ملكيه انه سعر
البيع على المواطنين بهذا الرقم
بعد التطور والتنظيم يعني اتكلم بالسابق
لانه سنوات كثيره بتكلم معك اليوم
العمل تنظم
وصار يعني
جهه واضحه مركزه تعمل على تطوير العمل في
المحطات في الطاقه في الخدمات يعني كن جدا
منظم وارتبط بالاسعار العالميه
فصار الطالع كله تشوف كل فتره ارامكو فعلا
السعر سعر البيع على المواطنين السعر
المعلن هذا هو اللي انت يعني تبيعه على
الناس فيه
من البايع من المبرد الرئيسي
والرقابه
في رق شديد وزاره التجاره قطاعات في رقابه
جدا وشلون يتاكدون انكم ماشيين في التسعير
ولا في الجوده ولا في غير
ما في انت ما تقدر تلعب
ثابت تمر انت لا من يوم تمر من عند المحطه
تلاقي الرقم يعني وصلنا اليوم ما كان
عندنا اول تمر من عند المحطه ما تدري مو
مكتوب شي اليوم
ما تقدر تمر من عند محطه ما عليها لوحه
والاسعار مكتوبه واللي يلعبون
طبعا هذه الصغيره
من زمان كانت المحطات شبع مانيوال وكان
فيه يعني القطاع هذا كان فيه من زمان تستر
ضخم كبير وكانوا الناس يعني العماله
يلعبون فيه يعني
يحرك فالسعر شيء بسيط يسمونه اللي هو
الوزن حقه يغير في الوزنيه يعني يعطيك لتر
يحسب عليك العداد لتر لكن هو اقل من لتر
فهو عنده وفر في المخزون ما يعطيك اياه
كامل
تشوف انت العداد ولا سيارتك فيها 100 لتر
فعليا ما فيها تسعين
الرقابه
والتنظيم العمل حددت الامور هذي كلها ممكن
تفاصيل اكثر يعني وش اللي يخلي يقفل على
العمال هذولي مثلا انه يتلاعبون هل في
اشتراطات معينه للاجهزه ولا وش اللي صار
بالضبط هي قصه كامله
يعني ركز الحكومه على تطوير محطات الوقود
ورفع جودتها
وعملوا وصلوا الى تاهيل شركات اللي تعمل
في محطات الوقود بناء على معايير جوده هذه
ما اعطت فرصه للعالم يعني العماله اللي
كانوا يديرون محطات وتستر فيها فضغطوا على
انقطاع في الرقابه والمتابعه الين نضف
واللوحات اللي ذكرتها
دائما التشريع دائما كل يوم شيء جديد
اشتراط السعر واضح العميل
والكلبريشن المكاين يعني عندك
لائحه طويله تعملها وتراقبها ولا اذا جاك
المراقب يعني
ما هي كويسه لا
سمعتك ولا
لثقه العملاء فيك
المحطات اللي تربحون منه
موحده المحطات المؤهله يعني اليوم في
محطات كثير في البلد ما هي مواهله وش
المهم
[موسيقى]
كانت كانت من وزاره
البلديات اليوم انتقل الملفي لوزاره
الطاقه فانت تتاهل بناء على على جوده
الخدمات على عناصر على الهويه لازم لك
هويه لازم كذا
على خدمه البنزين
تشارك كم تقريبا في البنزين يعني تطلع
الهوامش رسميا وتطلع يعني الشركات المؤهله
هامشها يختلف عن الشركه العاديه
وتشوف على طارق تستر اتصور الاجبار
المحطات يستخدمون المكائن اتوقع قتلت جزء
كبير وانت تستر ولا اول كان الشغل كله كاش
شو يطلع لك العامل رزمه كاش الحين تقريبا
انعدم المنظر ده
طبعا هذا التنظيم
ما في شك انه تنظيم جدا نجح في
قتل التستر في كثير من القطاعات من ضمنها
قطاع خدمات السيارات يعني محطات الوقود
وكذا يعني جدا صار منظم القروش الداخله
والطالعزيز جدا منظمه
يعني كان
التستر ملف
جدا شايك صعب
طبعا
الدوله اشتغلت على هذا الملف
وضعت لها هدف اشتغلت عليه شغل جدا منظم
مرتب بداوا يشتغلون عليه يطورون الين قضوا
على عدد كبير
التستر دائما يعني
سوسه الاقتصاد
هي دائما يضر الاقتصاد لانه هي عباره عن
فرص عمل
مبالغ ارباح
لمستثمر في وسط البلد
كنت في طريقها قاعده تطلعها من
الاستثمار اللي في البلد ومن النظام
ودائما التستر
يستخدم ناس يعني عماله ممكن ياخذ اعماله
سائبه اصل كل شغله غلط بغلط يمشي
بهالترتيب ويكمل بهالطريق
يسمونه
الذاتيه الخدمه الذاتيه احنا نطور في
الاعمال هذه لكنه هذه يبغى لها يعني هي
ماشيه مع التنظيم وانا اعتقد انه هدف من
اهداف تطوير المحطات انهم يعني شغالين على
الخدمه الذاتيه وعندهم برنامج جدا منظم هل
تعتقد الناس ما يبغونه
اذا حصل لي خدمه بتكون عاديه بدون يخدمني
واحد بدون ما اسوي شيء يمكن اكيد الناس
كانوا تدورون الراحه فنتوقع لكنه المفروض
يعني انا اعتقد انه فيها توفير كبير
للعماله وفيها يعني تنظيم ونظافه افضل
وكذا لكنه يعني لازم يكون عندنا هالخيار
ما له دخل في التشريعات او شيء انه ما طلع
لها
كلمه صار في تشريع على الجميع كلما سهل
تحقيقه هل يمنع وجود الخدمه الذاتيه
اي احد بيسويه تطوير عملي تطور انت اهلا
وسهلا ما تطور بيطورونك غصبا يعني لازم
تمشي على الطريقه يعني المميزه لتقديم
الخدمات حلو قبل ما ننتقل من عنصر البنزين
صراحه في
في سؤال في بالي قد يعتبر من الغاز الحياه
بالنسبه
وين راحت المناديل اللي تعطوني اياها
كنت بنزين اعطوني منديل وش سالفه من سالفه
المنديل وليش وقف
المنديل ذكرى ايام كان في عروض انه مناديل
رخيصه وكذا وقدمات واخذوها الناس نوع من
التسويق انه تجيني انا محطه بعطيك منديل
بعطيك قلم يعني
بدايه بدايه علم النقاط ما كانوا اول ما
في اول نقاط وما نقاط
انت يوم قلت
انه هذه من زمان
اذا عديتها تاخذ
المحطات ذي الايام يشتغلون لا تدري
المنديل
يشجعك ما فيها اي شيء مقارب الحين لا في
سبب
انه كان العدد قليل اليوم ما شاء الله
يعني كم عدد المحطات
النموس وكان يتطور في البلد العالم مركزه
على جوده الخدمه والعمل فيها وبداوا يعطون
خيارات ونقاط افضل بدل بدل العميل ما يعني
يقول لك لا عطني اشياء افضل من المنديل
والله ما في شيء
ينقطع في السياره
يسوي كذا في عود يعني طرق كثيره بدو الناس
يفضلونها بينتقل من العنصر حق البنزين
العنصر ثاني اللي هو التموينات كل الاشياء
الثانيه اللي عندكم كعناصر هو الوحيد اللي
تشغلون بانفسكم فهو اللي خلاكم ما
تتعاملون معاه بطريقه اللي عندي مثلا
مساحه التموينات باجرها لاحد يشغلها زيه
زي اي مطعم زي قهوه اي اي واحد ثاني في
محطاتكم اليوم برنامجنا التطوير للقطاع
اللي اشتغلنا فيه في المحطات واشتغلنا
عليه كان من اهم الاسباب فيه
انه يكون عندك
شركات تقدم خدمه مميزه
في اللي هي في
الاسواق او سوبر ماركت البقاله في المحطه
طبعا
ما كان يعني شركه اللي تقدم الخدمه هذه
شركه ما كان فيه الا شركه واحده
وشغاله في فروعها وعمالها ومحدوده ما هي
قاعده تنتشر بسرعه
شركات الثانيه
عندهم
دوخه الراس حقت بقاله صغيره تكلم 200 300
متر زي الفين متر نفس الاداره اداره مخزون
وعمل ومدير فرع وكل الخدمات
فما يعطونك يا ما يقدمون لك الخدمه اللي
انت تبغاها ولا تقدر تسيطر على الجوده
وعلى العمل زي ما لو انت جيت واسست لها
عمل يعني فريق عمل متخصص تعبانين من ناحيه
الكفاءه الاداره
الراي الممتاز
يشتغل معك يعني اروح فروع غير ولا يقدر
يمشي معك على عدد اللي انت تبغاه ممكن
يمشي معك في موقعين ثلاثه خمسه عشره مميزه
لكن ما راح يستمر معك فانت كنت متوسع
بسرعه
اليوم هذي ترى مشكله موجوده كثير كثير
يدور يعني يدور ناس مشغلين
هالقطاعنا لما جينا نبغى نطلع في جوده
هالمكان ونطلع من اللي قبل شوي الرصيف
مليان ثلاث ارباع البضاعه اللي في المحل
لازم تسوي له شركه عملنا شركه
وعملنا نخله اشتغلنا فيها
طورنا العناصر ما تدخل
النخله تجد
الجوده النظافه العناصر اللي موجوده
الخدمات
مكتمله
فانطلقنا في هذا المجال في العمل ومشينا
فيه واليوم اليوم عندنا فوق فوق الثمانين
فرع
كان الاساسي
ونشتغل في صعوبه كبيره فكان سبب الاساسي
تحتاجون شريك تقدرون تعتمدون عليه توسع
معكم في جميع
صار فيها صعوبه
لانه حنا مطالبين انه نعمل يعني محطه
مكتمله للعناصر زبون ما له علاقه الزبون
يبغى جوده في الخدمات كيف تسوي الجوده
سواها لقيت احد يسويها معاك بطريقه ولا
المستوى اللي انت تبغاه اهلا وسهلا ما
قدرت
تجيب زبائن اكثر الثاني المحطه
متكامله ما في واحد اليوم
اليوم العناصر المحطه كامله هي جزء لا
يتجزا جميع العناصر مع بعض اذا صارت
مكتمله يجون يعني اليوم انت يعني اقل
سياره تمشي 400 كيلو في البنزين
ليش وقف
يوقف يبغى خدماتي يبغى يصلي بخدمات بمطعم
سوبر ماركت يعني يبغى اي شيء موجود يعني
نكمل عناصر اسباب عديده للتوقف لانه بين
عناصر زي البقاله مثلا او محل قهوه
الاحتياج لها يومي فممكن تخليني اعبي
بنزين بالطريق بالنسبه
لنا والاسباب يعني كل واحد له سببه حلو
بعدين هذه بالنسبه للتموينات عندك
الصيانه والورش هذه انتم مشغولونها
بالكامل
مالكم علاقه فيها لانه
قطاع محدد يعني انت لما تجي قسم صيانه
السيارات دائما اول ما تفكر في قسم صيانه
يا مركز مستقل
وهذا يكون ضخ ومكلف كثير يا مركز ضمن محطه
بنزين
هذا المحطه حتكون افضل له واسرع
بهالطريقه
يكسروا هم واقفين طابور تختار هذا ولا هذا
والجدوى
من ناحيه موجود حلو دائما
تموينات
موجوده في كل
مختلف الاحجام يعني موجوده بس الحين مثلا
وفي بعد المطاعم بس قبل ما ادخل النقطه
الثانيه المطاعم اذكر قبل حلقه نسولف انه
في كان في مطعم عالمي شايف نفسه عليكم
سابق ههه
جينا حطينا العناصر حقتنا لازم نستقطب ناس
تكلمنا مع انا يعني شركات
هذه كانت اول محطه طورناها متكامله كانت
في طريق الدمام سنه
عملنا فيها مجموعه مجموعه مطاعم
فيها براندات محليه وعالميه كنت بتخبط
كل العناصر يعني
كلنا نعناه بطريقته
يعني زي اقول لك
بعض الشركات
الاجنبي من النقاش معهم
ووصلنا في اذكر في وحده من المحطات انه
جينا قلنا له تعال انت تعال سوى التجربه
حنا مستعدين اذا ما ضبطت معك حنا ندفع
التكلفه حقت خسارتك كل التشغيل
ديكور ومادير العمل حقه اللي سواه احنا
مستعدين
متردد واحنا ما نقدر ما نقبل احد متردد
معنا في العمل ولازم نجيبهم يعني لازم
كلهم يجوني ياخذونها التجربه وعارفين انه
اول وحده وثاني واحده حتكون مزعجه
يعني وضعنا كل قوتنا بعض البراندات
السعوديه كانت اسهل علينا
يعني في بعضها زملاء لنا بيني وبينهم
علاقه مميزه وقالوا والله اوكي هذا فرعين
نبغى نسويها
نشوف نجحت اهلا وسهلا اذا ما نجحت انه
احنا جربنا ما يكون علينا ان والله احنا
كنا ضد هالموضوع الين ينجح اذا كل الناس
احجمت عنك كيف ينجح وفي معين
مثلا تقول ابي النوع هذه من مطاعم ولا ترى
هذه فيها فتحات موجوده ابن ناجرها وبس
لازم يكون عندك نوعيات معينه يصير عندك
خلط على اساس انه عميلك يكون عنده خيارات
كثيره احد يبغى عنه ولا النوع الثاني فانت
دايم لازم عندك خيارات كثيره ما تدري
الناس وش اللي هم يبغونها
الكبيره خلط في المحطات عندنا جدا مميز
وبعد ما في وقت قياسي اسرع مما كنا نتوقع
حققوا
كل شركائنا ارقام جدا مميزه
وتحمسوا كثير وصارت العمليه سهله عندنا كل
ما نفتح يعني
محطه جديده نرسل لهم نلقاهم معنا نفتح سوا
في اغرب المحطات انت تو جبت لي محطه
المطار
محطه المطار قصه نجاح ثانيه
مجينا طبعا الموقع جدا مهم كانت منافسه
يعني
شرسه الين اخذنا الموقع
مجينا نسوي سوينا مع مع المطور معنا
طورنا العمل في هالمحطه سميناها ساسكو بلس
كانت على الجهتين من الطريق الاولى كانت
جهه واحده بل يعني قبل ما تبنى جامعه نوره
قبال جامعه نوره
فعملناها صارت عباره عن زي السوق مطاعم
ضخمه محلات كثيره
تقريبا جزء التطوير مطلبوا الفكره
التطويري حنا طرحنا عليهم
يعني المنافسه كان ذيك الايام اللي هو
الهدف المبلغ حلو يعني كم مبلغ الايجار
التشغيل وكذا اشتغلنا عليها وطورناها بعد
ما طورناها نجحت نجاح كبير
وساعدتنا في
سرعه الانتشار ساعدتنا اعطت رساله لكل
الناس اللي يشتغلون على هالمجال حق
المحطات انه يا جماعه احنا فعلا
ساسكو نعني التطوير ونبغى التطوير ونبغى
نوصل الهدف يعني الارتقاء بالخدمه وانه
نكون حنا بنش ماركر الاخرين في هذا
التطوير
فعلا ريحتنا كثير كثير من
المسؤولين او الناس اللي يمر عليهم
التطوير القطاع بدوي يرون شيء جدا مميز له
رده فعل كبيره عند متلقين الخدمات او
مستفيدين منها
فريحتنا وبدانا
نرتقي منها
المنافسين وجدوا انه استثمار ضخم
بهالطريقه فهذا المكان ونجح معناته يا
جماعه يعني
الزبون متعطش يبغى خدمه ممتازه يبغى عمل
ممتاز بداوا الناس يشتغلون اكثر في تطوير
القطاع المحطات مؤخرا بدات اجمالا قعدت
تكبر وتنظف وتتطور بشكل عكس السابق بعد ما
زلت الحين
ينقطع تطوير لكن تطوير القطاع طبعا
الى قبل اسبوعين محطتين
بنزل حقهم
ايش المشكله اللي صار هنا في الموضوع ده
والله ما ادري عن محطات الثانيه غريب
صراحه يعني ما ادري عنهم على التوريد يمكن
ما عندهم كذا حنا
حنا في ساسكو عندنا
رقابه كبيره بعدين يعني
تطويرنا لساسكو كان يعني من جميع جميع
العناصر
تطورنا عملنا شركه نقل
خاصه بنا وبدات تشتغل في السوق الاخرين
تغطي احتياجي لانه بيننا بعد سوينا شركه
للنقل المحطات ثانيه ما نبهي حسب علمك على
الاقل في في محطات تشترون من موردين يعني
يجيب لك ناس ينقلون لك يجيبوا لك ينقلون
الوقود يوصلونه لك مقاولين نقل وفي شركات
ثانيه لا نقل عندها اسطولها اللي ينقل
لانه بيني وبينك عنصر رئيسي من المحطات
عدم انقطاع الوقود
انقطاع الوقود ما هو ما هو من المورد
انا غالبا انقطع الوقود يجي من وين من انه
انت نقل ولا عرفت متى تغذي المخزون ما
عندك مراقبه حنا اليوم لا عندنا مراقبه
ضخمه او قويه على
المخزون وانقطاعاته وتعتبر عندنا مشكله
كبيره اذا صار انقطاع ولازم يبرر ويعني
نعم نادر عندنا لكنه لو حصلت لسبب ما
دائما تصير عندنا فيها مشكله اي مشكله
يلقى يلقى الماده اللي هو يبغاها مشكله
رقابه مخزون ونقل غالبا تكون متت متت تورد
في المحطه انت عارف كم استهلاك اليومي كم
تبيها يكون عندك احتياط
شركه ثانيه هي اللي
مسويين الاسطوره عشان نكمل على موضوع لانه
دائما انت اذا صار عندك سيطره على العناصر
اللي انت الرئيسيه بالنسبه لك وردتها انت
عندك السيطره التامه ودائما ما يصير عندك
مشاكل حلو هذه يمكن سؤال ثاني انت عندك كل
العناصر هذه قاعد تشتغل فيها سواء موضوع
المطاعم البنزين نقل البنزين التموينات
هذي كلها لها مشرعينها ما انت الحين
بالمعنى معناتها ان كان داخل مع سبعين
مشرع لانك تشتمشي على شرطات بلديه وعلى
اشتراطات بدري مين حتى المصليات
فعدد كبير مشرعين يتعاملوا معاه ولا
صحيح هي عليها لها تنظيمات
قالوا البقاله غيروا تنظيم جديد تغير كل
المقالات الحين يعني
مستوى عشان يصل للمستوى اللي احنا رافعينه
من زمان فدائما يعني التنظيمات اللي اذا
صار فيها اي تعديل او تنظيم دائما حنا
يعني يكون
شيء بسيط اللي يبغى له تعديل
ما في مشكله في كبيره او التنظيمات دائما
يعني اللي تشوفه الان تطلع تشريعات وكذا
هو رفع مستوى الخدمات لانه المستهلك
يحتاج الى رفع من خدمات وجوده
فدائما لما تشوف التنظيم هنا ونظم هنا او
ينظم عشان ايش عشان يرفع في جوده الخدمه
ويكون اسهل في الرقابه يعني متابعه
المشرعين المختلفين ما تعبت ما عندنا
مشكله لانه عارفين كل واحد والانظمه واضحه
حنا اننا نشتغل على
الاستاندر والتنظيم اللي موجود معهم شوي
موضوع الرقابه وانك تتابع المحطات ولا
الامور هذه كلها الان هل كله افترض من
كلامك ان كلها مرتبطه او بياناتها توصلكم
اول باول وش قاعد يصير في كل محطه
الاداه المشاكل هذه كلها مربوطه من خلال
التقنيه ولا لازم ما تقدر يعني
عندنا فريق عمل جدا مميز
ويعني يشتغلون على يعني الخدمات وجودتها
ومراقبتها واحده منها حقت الشريحه حقت
البنزين اللي تخلي الواحد يقدر يتحكم
هذه احنا يعني عملنا التطوير العمل في هذه
عباره عن شريحه تحطها عند
التانك حق البنزين حق التعبئه ويقرا
سيارتك
انت كعميل عندنا في شركه ثانيه ويعرف وش
الكميه اللي انت طالع بالخدمات يزودك فيها
من اي مكان هذه تعتبر يعني من حلول الدفع
والرقابه
شركات افراد كلها حتى عندنا كروت انت تقدر
تعبيها مسبقا وتجيب بناء على الكرت حقك
عبي لك في الخدمات ايش
مربوطه بالنت هي ولا
موجوده اللي يقراها
قصدي انا الحين اقدر اون لاين مثلا هذول
السياره هذي مسموح كذا السياره
طبعا هذه
لقد رواج كبير مع العملاء لانه عملت
كنترول كويس على صرفهم في المحروقات
بدل ما تعطي واحد مجموعه كروت لتر ثاني او
يستخدمها بطريقه معينه صارت لا يعني عليها
كنترول جميل
راح السواق حقك كيف يستخدمه وين يروح وين
يجي فهذه مهمه
بالضبط في المحطات غير الكنترول هل في
اشياء الناس ما يعرفون عنها ممكن نقابه
تقراها الماكينه
ما يقدر يروح يعبي سياره ثانيه طب انتم ما
شاء الله عودتنا على موضوع العناصر اللي
سويتوه في ساسكو مثلا شخص ابي ادخل في
السوق في محطتي انا مثلا
في احتياج اليوم في الرياض ولا في المدن
الكبيره بس خلنا نقول انا في مدينه خارج
الرياض وابي اسوي المحطه
ابدا فيه ذكرت نقطه ما ادري لها علاقه في
الموضوع هذا
محطه مؤهله والغير مؤهله اذا ببدا بحطها
انا بتصير غير مؤهله يعني لما ارفع
الخدمات فيها وتصير مؤهله ولا شي فرق بين
طبعا تاهيل المحطات
لعناه يعني له هويه لازم عند عده عناصر
لازم تمشي عليها
تعمل عليه على تطويرها غالبا يعني في ناس
يبداون في محطه وبعدين يكمل اذا انت من
الناس اللي تبغى تقول والله انا بخلق بسوي
لي هويه وبشتغل عليه وببدا اطور يصير
المحطه الاولى ثاني ثالثه الله يدير لك
ويقويك اذا تقول لا والله انا لا مالك لها
المحطه بس
فمالك للمحطه معناته مكلف عليك انك تعمل
الهويه وكيف تشغل تسوي لازم يعني الافضل
انك تروح للمهاليه شركات الماهله
تجي شركات الماهله شركات المؤهله دائما
يكون عندهم حلول
حنا بعطيك على اساسكم
انا عندي حلول نجي نستاجر من كل المحطه
اللي انت بانيها تكون على مواصفاتنا
ونعطيك المواصفات والهويه وتنفذها انا
راعي الارض
وتنفذ المحتاج تجاري يكون نظام مو بامتياز
قبل ما تجي نبدا احنا كذا خيارات بعطيك
الاول انه انت تيجي تبغى تتجرني عرض
تكون انت تبغى تبني على هويتي وكل شيء
تقول والله انا ما ابغى اجار منك ابغى
اشغل انا حنا عندنا حل عاملين شركه
للامتياز التجاري انا اعطيك امتياز ملف
متكامل عندي رقابه عليه عندي شروط العمل
فيه اعطيك اياها متكرر صرت انت ماخذ
امتياز
ساسكو وتدير المحطه والرقبه علي بس برجع
غير مؤهل وايش وضعه من غير مهلين ما مو
واضح الفرق بين الغير مؤهل والمؤهل لازم
يتاهل
يتاهل عدل اللي عنده في شروط كثيره
للتاهيل ترخيص واشتراطات كذا رخيص ان
النظافه للجوده تشطيب حق المحطه العناصر
اشياء كثيره غير مؤهل
في شركات في المحطات السابقه فيها مجال
يعني اللي كانوا الناس شغالين عليها يعني
شغالين لكن لازم يرفع المستوى
طبعا بس مسموح ابدا بشيء بسيط على شيء
نضيف محطات القديمه انساها
المحطه جديده مطوره نظيفه
خدمات
متكامله الله اقدر ابدا الا بمحطه مؤهل
الحين لازم نضيفها لا غير لا تصنيف غير
شركات افصل بين المحطه وبين الشركات
المؤهله حلفاء ببدا باللي ذكرته يقول شوي
تبون فيها او اني اقول انا ببدي المحطه
وبملكها وكل شيء بهويه
احساسكو باشتراطاتكم بس انتم تعالوا
شغلوها لي وخوذك مشاركه ارباح ولا مشاركه
دخل
الثاني حق اللي انا
تكلمنا عنه الامتياز امتياز الثاني قلنا
اول شيء ثاني امتياز قلنا اجاره اول شيء
الايجار انه استاجر منك وانا اكمل شغلي
الخيار الثاني انه الامتياز انا اعطيك
الامتياز التجاري انا اعطيك شروطي تنفذها
على حقي
الثالث اللي هي يسمونها اللي هو مشاركه
بالربح انا اجي اشوف المحطه حقتك وادرسها
وبناء عليه
انا اعطيك العرض اقول لك والله هذه المحطه
بهالطريقه بعمل فيها بهالطريقه وانه بيكون
بيني وبينك مشاركه بالربح لا اتفاقيه تصير
عنها وبيننا بالمبيعات
بتحولها الى ثلاث طبعا ما في ما في شيء
تجاري انا اشغلها والمشاركه ارباح انتم
انا اللهم ابنيها لكم
واطلع من السالفه المشاركه بارباح اني
نشغل كل شيء حلو ونطلع من السالفه بس
السوق تشوفوا اليوم هذا يحتاج مع وجودكم
موجود ادريس وارامك
يعني اليوم هل في مجال الافرادي
اليوم اليوم طالع المحطات الموجوده في
البلد عدا الضخم
المشغلين الرئيسيين للشركات المصنفه يعني
ما اعتقد انهم يصلون 20% 25% من المحطات
اللي موجوده في البلد
بالعكس مجال التطوير والعمل فيه انا اعتقد
انه واعد جدا حتى مع توجهنا وهذا اتوقع
المستقبل البعيد خاصه في السعوديه خاصه
سياره الكهربائيه
حتى مع
سيارتكم حاليا اليوم المحطات
ما صارت المحطه بس
عندكم
عندنا مركبين في المطار في محطتين موجوده
وننتظر يعني نهايه تشريع تشريع حقه او
نظامها وطريقتها لكن
حطينا في المحطات للشحن الكهربائي انا لسه
ما طلع عليه الان
يعني موجوده ركبناها حنا في في ساسكو
دائما
نطبح انت دائما نكون مميزين ونكون سباقين
الاشياء كلها جميع الخدمات تطويرها
وتقديمها لذلك يعني كان واجب علينا انه
على طول بيجي نامن الاجهزه ونرتبها وننتظر
الين يجي وقت التشريع جاهزين للموضوع ده
اي
اتكلم عن المنافسين الان اول شيء في
المنافسين في المنافسين بشكل مباشر ولا
غير مباشر المباشر اللي هم محطات الثانيه
زي ادريس
كم عدد محطاتكم اليوم مقارنه في اعداد
محطاتهم عدد محطاتهم اساسكم كم محطه اليوم
نعتبر رقم اثنين كم محطه حنا اليوم في
ساسكو اكثر من 500
ما شاء الله اكثر من رقم واحد
العدد اليوم ادريس كم تقريبا والله ما
ادري بس متجاوز الستميه حلو بس انتم ما
شاء الله مركزين واضح على جوده التجربه في
المحطه اكثر من
هذا اساسي عندنا انه الجوده والمحطات تطلع
بطريقه معينه يعني
عندنا مهمه وفي برضو ودخلت وهم نفسه الحين
دخلوا في محطاتهم
في مجال للاستثمار وفي رفع يعني رفع
الجوده
والخنا اكثر من شركه بس ليش تعتقد نفس
المزود دخل بنفسه في في محطات كان في
شراكه مع شركه المقطع الخاص بس ليش تخرج
محطات ويبغى حسب ما اذكر في خبر سابقا
قريته
يعني ليش ما اعتمدوا على الشركات الكبيره
زيكم
قبل شوي
انه كل المشغلين اللي موجودين الان ما
تجاوز العشرين 25% من المحطات اللي موجوده
في البلد فما نات في مجال يعني 75 الباقيه
كيف بتتطور
في دخول شركات ثانيه يساعد على سرعه
التطوير
فممكن هم عشان يرفعون نسبه المحطات
المؤهله في انفسهم لتسريع النموة ممكن هم
هم الان دخلوا في كذا محطه ووزعوا نماذج
ممتاز اشتغلوا عليها هويتهم يعني جيده
واعتقد انه يعني شيء داعم داعم كثير
للقطع
وهذا بالنسبه لنفسنا
في تهديد من دخول
اعتقد انه
ارامكو دخولها القطاع المحطات
انه اضافه كبيره اضافه كبيره
الارض الواقع هو يشوفون متطلبات العميل
وشي يبغى وين طموحه وين ترتكب الخدمات
وهذه تساعد كثير يعني حنا بالاول
نعتبر حنا من قدام
قدر القطاع
للتطور اللي موجود اليوم
محطاتنا في المحطات اللي موجوده في البلد
في 2009 شوفوا المحطات اليوم
نق
كبيره جدا
انه يعني صرنا حنا بنش مارك لكثير منهم
ولا زلنا حنا البنج مارك
دائما
[موسيقى]
يعني اسرع واسرع حلو فهذا بالنسبه
للمنافسين المبشرين في الغير مباشرين يعني
للامانه ما شفت يعني
تواجد كبير لهم اللي هم ممكن الشركات
الناشئه الجديده اللي بدات تقدم خدمه
توصيل البنزين البيوت بحيث انك انا محتاج
اروح المحطه انتم خدماتها بس
مع وجود الخدمات هذه يمكن ما احتاج اروح
محطه اساسا البنزين يجيني للبيت وشركه كان
في محاولات في البدايه شفت كم شركه تحاول
تشتغل فيها بصراحه ما تابعت الموضوع بعد
كذا
فهل اصلا مسموح اليوم انك تزود تزود الناس
بالبنزين في بيوتهم وكيف تشوف المنافسه مع
الشركات الناشئه هذيك
عباره عن شاحنات
مواصفات عالميه يعمل فيها في يعني اكثر
دول العالم
جبنا عدد من الشاحنات
وبدانا في
عمل تجربه اختبار السوق فيها وكذا وبدينا
نعمل في هذا
الخدمه للعملاء
وننتظر تنظيم الرئيسي لها واعتقد انه خلاص
يعني
فتره بسيطه
نتبلغ فيه
لكن حنا جاهزين
سياراتنا جاهزه
اسطولنا مرتب للانطلاق بالخدمه هذه فما
خليتها مجال لحد شوف
وا اليوم
عيون الناس عليها
مطالع تطوير الخدمات العمل فيها تجد انه
جوده جدا عاليه
وطموحنا طموح القياده دائما ما في طموح
الا رقم واحد
فهذا الطموح لازم انت تحافظ عليه وتنفذه
تستمر فيه بس ما تشوف عندهم يعني لما تيجي
تطالع تقنيا كيف الدوله تطورت الخدمات كيف
تطورت في اشياء كثيره تطورت فانت من
الاشياء البسيطه انه تصل الى جوده انه
والله انا اوكي انا مداوم تعال العب
سيارتي واروح بس ما تحسن نموذج هذا يمشي
عكس الشيء اللي تبغى تسويه فهو بدال ما
انت قاعد تنهجر للناس انت قاعد تقول له
خلاص لا تجيني التجربه اللي انا في الخدمه
الخدمه لازم تطورها
تبي تجيني بكره اذا صرت عميل عندي فجيتني
ممكن الهدف غير البنزين
تجي لاهداف اخرى توقف تنزل ترتاح تصلي
تقضي
بس ما تعتقد هذا بيلغي الاحتياج زي مثلا
ما صار مع المطاعم زي ما صار حتى الصيانه
الحين صار فيه تطبيقات تطلب الصيانه للبيت
عندك ما تحس انه هذا ممكن يحول محطات
مستقبلا طبعا شبه مستحيل بس ما تدري يعني
كنا نقول على اشياء مستحيل سابقا وصارت
واقع الان بس ما هل ممكن بعدين خلاص ما
يحتاجون يروح محطات انه انا اقدر اطلبها
وتجي عندي ما تقدر تلغي الاحتياج اليوم
المحطات جدا مكلفه تنفيذها
والمحافظه عليها واذا جدا مكلف تقديم
الخدمه برضو يخفف عليك الزحمه في المحطات
اوكي
طبعا في بعض المناطق بعض الشوارع فيها
زحمه مغلقه
فهي خدمه انت لازم تقدمها نمو
نمو السكاني توسع العمل الشركات هذه كلها
تحتاج الى زياده خدمه ترفع ما تقدر تتوازع
الى لين تاخذ جزء شريحه كبيره من العملاء
وتقدم الخدمه لهم في محلهم عشان ايش انت
يعني تقدر تقدم خدمه افضل في الموقع
الرئيسي وتمسك العميل معك
أفكر فيها من ناحيه انه كل الخدمات
المحطات اليوم توصل للبيت
بقاله كل شيء صار يتوصل وبسرعه باقي
البنزين اللي موجود احنا جاهز عملنا تجربه
جدا ناجحه
بس جاهزين من الظاهر انه ما في وقت طويل
يعني جزء بسيط وقت قصيره ان شاء الله
خدمتكم موجوده الشركه الوحيده يمكن الخدمه
بس كان وقت الزنقات ما بيذكر رسمه غير
قانوني بس كانوا عندهم جوالين من نوع معين
يعطونها للمندوب يروح محطه بنزين يعبيها
ويج ب عليك البيت يعني
عاليه جدا يعني مع بنزين
ماده سريعه الاشتعاء لا مواصفات حلو تشوف
السيارات اللي حنا يعني جايبينها وتقدم
الخدمات
كيف النظام الامام فيها جدا عالي فهذه
يعني
انا اعتقد انه جركل وتحطه
لازم سياره مؤهله مواصفات وهذه يمكن هي من
الاشياء اللي يعني
خلت المشرع انه يضغط ما يطلع شيء لا جدا
مقنع على شروط امن وسلامه انهم بالهدف بس
ما عاد تعبي بنزين وتمشي
على بالي بنزين عند محل مكتظ بالسيارات
لاي سبب ما صار عنده حريق حريق للمحل كله
سيارات كلها شارع كبير مو صحيح طبعا قبل
ما اختم معك في سؤال بس قبل ما قبل ما
نروح له ودي اشوف يعني تلخص لي الرحله هذه
حقت
2009 الى اليوم وتعطيني بشكل عام وش كيف
كانت وش صارت اليوم سواء من احد ايرادات
سواء راحت خدمات تعطيني بس
اختصار لهالرحله بشكل سريع
والله رحله طويله
لكن بعطيك مختصر ومختصر يعني حنا
ما استحوذنا على اساسك اذكر انه
مكتب حقي كان حوالي 800 متر
اليوم مكاتب الادارات عندنا عشره الاف ما
شاء الله
موظفينها كانوا
العاملين في سياسكو الظهر ما يتجاوزون 500
اليوم فوق ال5000
مصليات اليوم وصلت اما يعني مساجد ما بين
مساجد مصليات ما صار عندنا اليوم حوالي 25
الف متر
ما بين مساجد مصليات ايرادات واجر
اللي على الايرادات المبيعات
الظاهر كانت حوالي 190 مليون
سنه مئه مليون في السنه اليوم
تجاوزنا 8 مليار
المحطه الواحده كم الدخل تقريبا
بالموقع حسب كذا يعني هذه الاشياء اسطول
النقل
ما كان عندنا اليوم عندنا فوق الثلاث مئه
تريله
كان عندنا اعتقد
مستحوذنا 39 محطه بعضها غير عامل
يعني اما الطريق يتحول عنها ولا شخص كذا
فما كانت يعني كذا اليوم تتكلم اكثر من
500 محطه
في محطات اضطرينا تخرج منها
عشان الطريق تغير زي ما ذكرته طريقه غير
طلع خدمات مختلفه الموقع غير مناسب يعني
في اشياء كثير تخرجنا منها
هذيك الايام الظاهر اللي كان ملك خمس
محطات
اليوم عندنا فوق الستين محطه ملك بس عادت
قليل اللي هو ما زال لسبب لسرعه التوسع
ولا الملك في مشكله ما يعتبر عدد جدا طيب
عندنا من اكثر من اكثر المحطات تملك يعني
اكثر الشركات تملك في المحطات قصدي عدم
تملككم لاكثر من 60 محطه من اصل 500 ترى
التملك 60 يعتبر جدا ضخم
محطات مكلفه فيعتبر ضخم حسب يعني
اذا ما تقدر تتملك كل شيء وسرعه النمو
عندك مهمه مكلفه ليش التكلفه تكاليف
المحطه عاليه وش اكثر الاراضي ولا والبناء
غير العقار غير الارض
رئيسي بس تشغيليا مكلفه ايضا انت مشغل
مشغل للايجار ولا البناء
كاستثمار يعتبر استثمار عالي ولا تقدر
تتملكه كله
فمنها العناء يعني هذه يعني هذه اللي
اعطيتك زبده الرحله في الارقام اللي
موجوده في الخدمات غير اللي هو الارتقاء
والجوده فيها كم مدينه
حلمت تقريبا المملكه
للسؤال الاخير الان ولو ترجع يرجع فيك
الوقت لاول يوم ما بيقول ساسكو ليله
الى اول يوم بس بنفس المعلومات اللي ما
عندك اياها اليوم ونفس الخبره ونفس
التجارب وش تعتقد الاشياء اللي بتغيرها
والمشاكل اللي بتجنبها من ذاك الوقت بعطيك
اياه بطريقه ثانيه
لو قلت لي يعني تقولي الان وش كان سويت لو
رجع بكل وقت وكذا انا اقول لك لو
التشريعات
والتنظيمات
موجوده زي اليوم بوضوحها بشفافيه وبسرعتها
كان اليوم الارقام اضعاف ما تشوف
لانه حيوفر عليه وقت كثير في المراجعات في
التنظيم في الاشياء اليوم احنا تطورنا
بالعمل تقريبا حكومه الكترونيه
الفسوحات التنظيم التشريعات لكل جزء بسيط
له تنظيم لو تشريعات هذه الاشياء كانت اول
غيابها كان ياخر العمل زي ما قلت لك في
اول اللقاء جلسنا سنه في اول ترخيص ليس
يعني ان العمل البس ما كانت الامور
بهالوضح وها الطريقه اليوم لا الامور جدا
واضحه وجدا سهله مقننه امشي على النظام
وامشي
هذه التجربه لو بهالوقت وهالتنظيم كان
اختلف الارقام لكن المهم
انه احنا اعطينا العمل حقه
جدا مرتاحين النتيجه بفضل من الله افضل
مما توقعنا ومن يعني طموحنا اللي كان ردت
فعل
عميلنا كانت جدا ايجابيه وجيده
بقول لك لا تعتقد الحناء يعني وصلنا احنا
دائما كل ما نقرب من عند الهدف ونروح
نبعده نروح للتطوير احيانا نحقق اهدافنا
قبل الجدول اللي موضوع لها ونمدها زياده
وان شاء الله انه احنا حنستمر في تطوير
القطاع والعمل يعني لتحقيق افضل خدمات
وارضاع لعميلنا الله يعطيك العافيه ابو
محمد اثريتنا اليوم في الحلقه كثير لكن
الله لاختك فبنوقف نظر نوقف اللقاء الان
فشكرا لك الله يعافيك ويسلمكم ويعطيكم
برنامجكم جدا شيق جدا مفيد
كثير من الناس يعني الجيل الجديد بدو
يعتمدون عليه يروحون للحلقات وياخذ منه
ويصير مرجع عنده صارت مكتبه صوتيه عندهم
هذا المطلوب يعني موفقين ان شاء الله والى
المزيد الله يعطيك شكرا جزيلا شكرا شكرا
قبل ما تقفلوا الحلقه اتمنى اذا عجبتك
تشاركها مع اللي حولك وتقيمها بتقييم
ايجابي سواء في اليوتيوب او في ايتونز
واذا كان عندكم ملاحظات عنها ياريتك
تشاركني اياها سواء على ايميل البرنامج
سوالف ثمانيه او حتى على حسابي في تويتر
ات دبيان شكرا لمتابعتكم وشكرا لعبد الملك
ال سعيد في اعداد الحلقه ياسر الغانم في
اداره التصوير في الاضاءه غالب محمد
ومساعده وياسر كدشه في الاخراج الابداعي
وهاب موسى في الاخراج الفني مجد القرشي
فالمندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز المزي في
التحرير برامج بيبان في التجهيز عبد
المجيد عمر عبد الله بن الفقيه محمد عبد
العزيز او في الانتاج التنفيذي رزاند هيثم
بزنس احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع